Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. It is an infallible law of the internet that anyone who gets into an argument on social media in due course will end up being accused of being Adolf Hitler. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History with me, Tom Holland and Dominic Sandbrook. Dominic, you must have been accused of being Hitler a fair number of times over the course of your career, have you? Many times.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、无广告内容、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。互联网有一条颠扑不破的定律：任何在社交媒体上参与争论的人，最终都会被指责为阿道夫·希特勒。你好，欢迎收听《历史的余味》，我是汤姆·霍兰，还有多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。多米尼克，在你的职业生涯中，你一定被指责过不少次是希特勒吧？很多次。
I think you can't say anything in public now without people at some point saying you're a Nazi. No matter what position you hold, that sort of accusation hangs over you like a sword of Damocles, doesn't it? So in a sense, today's episode is on Adolf Hitler. And there's a sense in which this is a subject that this entire series of podcasts has been building up to because our very first episode was around the issue of of what role does great men play when set against the kind of sweep of vast forces and that is a
我想现在你在公共场合说什么，人们迟早都会说你是纳粹。无论你持什么立场，那种指责就像达摩克利斯之剑一样悬在你头上，不是吗？所以从某种意义上说，今天的节目是关于阿道夫·希特勒的。在某种程度上，我们整个播客系列一直在为这个主题做铺垫，因为我们的第一集就是围绕“伟人在浩瀚的历史洪流中扮演什么角色”这一议题展开的，而这正是
theme that we have explored several times. And another theme that we've explored is the nature of morality, whether we can talk about topics such as evil in the context of historical inquiry, where our ideas of evil come from. So it does feel that today we are drawing together quite a lot of strands, aren't we? Yes, because I think Hitler is one of the, I mean, we had a podcast about Mohammed, obviously, some listeners will know, we've talked about figures such as Nero that, you know, are sort of entrenched in our imagination, but Hitler probably dwarfs them all, doesn't he? He's the most familiar non-religious, well, we can talk later on about whether he is, has almost become a kind of quasi-religious figure, but he's the most familiar non-religious figure, I think, in all
我们多次探讨过的主题。我们探讨的另一个主题是道德的本质，即我们是否可以在历史探究的背景下讨论“邪恶”这类话题，以及我们对邪恶的观念从何而来。所以，今天我们确实是在将许多线索汇聚在一起，不是吗？是的，因为我认为希特勒是……我的意思是，我们显然做过一期关于穆罕默德的播客，一些听众会知道，我们也谈论过像尼禄这样在我们的想象中根深蒂固的人物，但希特勒的影响力可能使他们相形见绌，不是吗？他是最广为人知的非宗教人物——好吧，我们稍后可以讨论他是否几乎已经成为一种准宗教人物——但我认为，他是所有
human history, and one with, you know, that he has become a benchmark, I guess, hasn't he, for morality, for a particular kind of political leadership. And he is the lens through which we view the last hundred years of history, right? Absolutely. I absolutely agree. And I think that a topic this massive and this well-known needs a great historian to hold our hands as we tip to across the minefield that is this subject. And Dominic, by great good fortune, I think you got your first job from our greatest living biographer of Hitler, didn't you? I did. Well, I did. So in 2001, I went for a job interview at the University of Sheffield. And the terrifying thing was that the chair of the panel was our guest today,
人类历史上最广为人知的非宗教人物，而且他已经成为道德和某种特定政治领导力的标杆，不是吗？他是我们审视过去一百年历史的透镜，对吧？绝对是。我完全同意。而且我认为，这样一个宏大且广为人知的话题，需要一位伟大的历史学家来牵着我们的手，带我们穿过这个充满地雷的主题。多米尼克，非常幸运的是，我想你第一份工作就是我们当今最伟大的希特勒传记作家给你的，对吧？是的。没错。所以2001年，我去谢菲尔德大学参加了一次面试。最可怕的是，面试小组的主席就是我们今天的嘉宾，
Sir Ian Kershaw, as he became a couple of years later. And I can remember sort of going into the interview, quaking in my boots, knowing that you're going into an interview with somebody who, for many people, is the sort of acme of historical scholarship, which is why it's astounding to me that having offered me the job, Ian, you know, his credibility remained unimpaired. And it's great. It's really great to have him on the podcast. Ian, thank you so much for doing this. It's a real pleasure for us to have you. Of course, pleasure. So, Tom, do you want to kick off because
也就是几年后被封爵的伊恩·克肖爵士。我记得当时走进面试室时，我双腿发抖，因为我知道你要面对的是一位在许多人眼中代表了历史学术巅峰的人，所以令我震惊的是，在录用我之后，伊恩，你的信誉竟然丝毫未损。能请你来参加播客真是太棒了。伊恩，非常感谢你来参加。我们能请到你真是荣幸之至。当然，这是我的荣幸。那么，汤姆，你想开始吗？因为
you and ian have something in common um in terms of what you've written about and it's not hitler well one of the things that that fascinates me about biographers of hitler and people who are famous for studying hitler is that lots of them didn't begin as specialists in the field of nazi germany so alan bullock began as a classicist. Hugh Trevor Roper, I think, studied classics, didn't he? And his first book was on 17th century politics. And Ian, you began as a specialist in medieval abbeys, I think. Is that right? Before going on to write about Hitler. So how was it that you ended up writing about Hitler when your background was in medieval history? Well, I was an absolutely committed medievalist,
你和伊恩有一些共同点，嗯，就你们写过的内容而言，那不是希特勒。好吧，关于希特勒的传记作者和那些以研究希特勒而闻名的人，让我着迷的一点是，他们中的许多人最初并不是纳粹德国领域的专家。艾伦·布洛克最初是研究古典学的。休·特雷弗-罗珀我想也是学古典学的，对吧？他的第一本书是关于17世纪政治的。而伊恩，你最初是中世纪修道院的专家，我想没错吧？在开始写希特勒之前。那么，当你的背景是中世纪历史时，你是怎么最终写起希特勒的呢？嗯，我曾经是一个绝对坚定的中世纪主义者，
passionate medievalist, and it came about very gradually and came about through the German language, really, that I never anticipated in a million years ever coming to be preoccupied with Hitler or Nazi Germany. But I had a very, I went to start just by chance, learning German at the Goethe-Institut in Manchester, by the time that I began as a lecturer in medieval history at Manchester University. They just opened a branch in Manchester, the Goethe Institute, and we had an inspired, a wonderful teacher there who enthused us with everything to do with Germany, which was, and I became interested in all sorts of things, not just history of Germany. The learning German, which I was unable to do while learning any other language, modern language,
一个充满激情的中世纪主义者，这一切发生得非常缓慢，而且确实是通过德语实现的。我做梦也没想到自己会沉迷于希特勒或纳粹德国。但我当时在曼彻斯特大学开始担任中世纪历史讲师时，偶然在曼彻斯特的歌德学院开始学习德语。他们刚在曼彻斯特开设了分院，我们有一位充满灵感、非常棒的老师，他让我们对与德国有关的一切都充满了热情，我开始对各种事物感兴趣，不仅仅是德国历史。学习德语——这是我在学校和大学时除了法语外无法学习的任何现代语言——对我来说只是一个爱好。我根本没打算出于任何特定原因使用它，直到1972年，我获得了歌德学院提供的去德国留学的奖学金。我在那里待了两个月，德语水平提高得非常快。我带了许多关于中世纪历史的书，结果发现自己读起了关于纳粹德国的东西。在那段时间里，我确信自己真的想开始调查一个非常明显的问题：为什么像那样一个拥有丰富文化历史的国家，
other than French at school and university, was just something which was a hobby for me. I had no intention of using it for any particular reason until 1972, when I got the option to go on a scholarship to Germany from the Goethe-Institut. I spent two months there, improved my German very rapidly by this time. And I took numerous books with me on medieval history and found myself reading stuff on Nazi Germany. And in that period, I then convinced myself that I wanted really to start investigating a very obvious question, why a country like that with all its rich cultural history
竟然会陷入纳粹主义。从那时起，一切就开始了。这是一个非常漫长的转变，一个漫长的故事，但那确实是开始。伊恩，有没有这样一个故事，说你在70年代和某个人，或者某个德国公众成员交谈过，他对你说，
then should descend into Nazism. And that took off from there onwards. It was a very long conversion, a long story, but that's when it began, really. And isn't there some story, Ian, that you spoke to somebody in the 70s or a German, a member of the public, who said to you,
哦，你是英国人，你站错了队，你应该和我们并肩作战之类的？是的，那是在1972年，我在慕尼黑附近20英里处的一个小镇待了两个月期间发生的。那是一个潮湿的周日，我坐在咖啡馆里看报纸打发时间，这个家伙开始和我聊天。起初只是平淡的对话。
oh, you're British, you fought on the wrong side, you should have fought with us or something like that? Yes, well, that was just during that two-month stay in a very small town about 20 miles from Munich in 1972. And I was just winding away the time on wet Sunday and sitting in a cafe reading a paper, and this chap got talking to me. And it was just a banal conversation initially.
然后他对我说了句，你一个英国人怎么会在这种小地方？我告诉了他，然后他开始说，我被这段对话迷住了。我说，哦，你们英国人，当然，他没说不列颠人，他说你们英国人，真是太蠢了。你们本该和我们一起参战，我们本可以瓜分世界。那一刻，我完全被这段对话吸引住了。但有一句话或一个短语我永远不会忘记。那对我来说非常说明问题，他在对话中曾说：“犹太人是虱子。”我从未遇到过类似的事情，我当时感到非常
And then he then said to me, what's you as an Englishman doing in a small place like this? And I told him and then he began and I became fascinated by the conversation. I said, oh, you English, of course, he didn't say British, you English, you're so stupid. You should have come into the war with us and we could have divided up the world. And I was absolutely gripped by the conversation at this point. But there was one sentence or phrase which I never forgot. And that was very telling for me, where at one point he said in the conversation, the Jew is a louse. And I've never come across anything remotely like that at all and I was so
震惊，但同时又被这个评论所吸引，我只是想知道在纳粹时代，像这样的小镇里到底发生了什么。那是促使我走上我已经在思考的道路的导火索之一，然后，你知道，几年后，我发现自己在阅读20世纪30年代那个小镇的警察报告。真的很神奇，但这只是通往这次转变的指路标之一，正如我所说，这花了一些时间。直到1975年，我想，我最终在曼彻斯特大学获得了一份现代历史的工作，我才真正成为了一名成熟的现代主义者。即便如此，第一年，我度过了相当疯狂的一年，我根本不知道门外的学生
shocked but fascinated at the same time by this comment and I just wondered what had gone on in a small town like this during the Nazi era and that was one trigger that pushed me on the way that I was already thinking of going and then you know a few years later I found myself reading the the police reports for that very town in that small town in the 1930s amazing really but it was one it was one pointer on the way to this conversion which took as I said some while and it wasn't until I eventually got a job in modern history at Manchester University in 1975 I think it was that I that I then became a fully-fledged modernist. And even then, the first year, I had one fairly crazy year where I never knew whether the students outside the door
是来学习开放式耕作制度的起源，还是来学习纳粹的崛起。在那之后，一切都稳定了下来。最终，你写了一本希特勒的传记。我想这是一个显而易见的问题，也是我们在整个对话过程中可能会反复探讨的问题。但纳粹德国的研究在多大程度上就是希特勒的研究？嗯，很明显，希特勒是纳粹德国研究的中心点、核心焦点。然而，当然，他并不是全部。而且，我必须补充一点，我写希特勒传记几乎是偶然的。
were coming in to learn about the origins of the open fuel system or the rise of the Nazis. After that, it settled down. And in due course, you end up writing a biography of Hitler. And I suppose it's the obvious question, and it's the question that we'll probably be fencing around over the course of our entire conversation. But to what extent is the study of Nazi Germany, the study of Hitler? Well, it's obvious that Hitler is the central point, central focus of that study of Nazi Germany. Yet, of course, he's not the whole story. And, of course, I should add that I came to write a biography of Hitler almost by chance.
我的意思是，通过德国社会史的途径，因为起初我根本对希特勒这个人不感兴趣。我感兴趣的是为什么德国人民会迷上纳粹主义，说得非常粗糙一点。显然希特勒在其中占有一席之地，但根本没想过要写希特勒的传记。企鹅出版社，也就是我传记最终的出版商，曾找过我，但我拒绝了，因为我说我不想写希特勒的传记。
I mean, through the route to through German social history, because initially I wasn't interested in Hitler as a person at all. I was interested in why the German people fell for Nazism, really, putting it very crudely. And obviously Hitler figures in that, but there was no thought of writing a biography of Hitler. And I was approached by Penguin, the eventual publisher of my biography initially, and I turned it down because I said, I've no wish to write a biography of Hitler.
然后我重新考虑了一下，重读了布洛克和约阿希姆·费斯特那本领先的德国希特勒传记，最终决定还是写一本。所以希特勒是核心人物，但他绝不是纳粹主义的全部历史。事实上，直到20世纪80年代，甚至更晚，许多德国史学界实际上都避开了希特勒，因为他们认为专注于希特勒就像是在为他辩护，这实际上是在削弱关于纳粹主义的关键问题，而专注于某一个体是具有误导性的，实际上是将历史过度集中在某一个体身上，无论该个体多么重要。你在写传记时是否发现希特勒的名声几乎令人压抑，
And then I thought it through again and reread Bullock and reread the leading German biography of Hitler by Joachim Fest and decided I would write one after all. So Hitler is the central figure, but he's by no means the entire history of Nazism and much German historiography until the 1980s really, if not later, actually turned away from Hitler because they thought Hitler was, focusing on Hitler was like an apologia, that it was really detracting from the key questions about Nazism and focusing upon one individual was misleading and was actually to centralise history too much in the case of one individual, however important that individual was. And did you find when you were writing your biography that Hitler's fame was almost oppressive,
以至于你无法像看待其他人一样看待他？或者说，希特勒作为这种恶魔偶像的意识，有时是否变得几乎让人难以承受？不，我从一开始就排除了恶魔偶像，因为我觉得那根本没有帮助。从某种意义上说，名声或恶名是一个不同的问题，因为无论你读到或了解到关于希特勒的什么，特别是来自他同时代人的评价，要么是极度赞成，要么是极度反对。所以同时代人看待希特勒时没有中立性。在处理原始资料时，这很难应对，因为你
that you could see him as a character like any other? Or was the consciousness of Hitler as this kind of demonic icon? Did that sometimes become almost overwhelming? No, I shut out the demonic icon right from the very beginning, because I didn't see that was helpful at all. The fame or the notoriety was a different issue in a sense that whatever you read or read about Hitler, particularly from his contemporaries, was either extremely for or extremely against. So there was no neutrality in contemporaries viewing Hitler. And that was quite, in terms of source material that you're dealing with, that's quite hard to cope with because you're
处理的材料要么是宣传材料，旨在建立希特勒的传奇形象，要么就是以各种可以想象的方式诋毁他，并编造关于他的负面故事，这些故事很难证实或证伪。所以这就是在处理史料方面的困难，而不是我所摒弃的恶魔形象。那么，关于希特勒与纳粹主义发展大趋势的关系，我们有两个问题。一个来自名叫“矮个子”（The Short One）的人。
dealing with stuff which is either propaganda material or aimed at building up a legendary image of Hitler, or else it's decrying him in every conceivable fashion and inventing negative stories about him which are very difficult to prove or disprove. So that was the difficulty in terms of Reichsmarting, not the demonic image which I discarded. So in terms of the relationship of Hitler to the broader trend of the development of Nazism, we've got two questions. We've got a question from somebody called The Short One.
如果没有希特勒这个人物，纳粹主义还会发生吗？其他纳粹领导人能做到他所做的事吗？还有一个来自“50多岁的加德纳”（50-something Gardner），另一个响亮的名字。伟人理论，如果没有希特勒，20年代末到30年代末在德国发生的事情有多少会照样发生？所以我猜这些问题聚焦了核心议题。希特勒对纳粹主义的故事有多重要？是的。这是一个重要的问题，而且不容易回答。但如果你回顾纳粹主义的前史，你会发现希特勒在掌权时，特别是在20世纪20年代初所表达的内容，来自一种丰富的类似种族主义民族主义思想背景，他只是其中的众多倡导者之一。所以在那一点上，希特勒反映了当时在
Would Nazism have happened without the figure of Hitler? Could any other of the leading Nazis have done what he did? And one from 50-something Gardner, another splendid name. Great man theory, how much of what happened in Germany in the late 20s through to late 30s would have happened anyway without Hitler? So I guess those questions focus the issue. How central is Hitler to the story of Nazism? Yes. And it's an important question and it's one that's not easy to answer. But if you look back at the prehistory of Nazism, you see then that what Hitler was articulating when he when he says when he arrives to power, particularly in the early 1920s, came from a rich background of similar racist nationalist thinking of which he was only one amongst many exponents. So at that point, Hitler was reflecting ideas which had a wider currency
极端激进种族主义右翼中具有更广泛影响的思想。当然，这只是德国政治中的一股潮流，甚至不是关键主题，但在第一次世界大战后变得更加流行。所以希特勒是其中的一个倡导者。后来，我认为1925年纳粹党的重建就是其中一个时刻，希特勒成为了一个不可替代的因素，因为纳粹运动，实际上就像你看到的几乎所有法西斯运动一样，容易受到派系斗争和分裂的影响。当希特勒在1924年被监禁几个月时，你看到了这一点，被取缔的纳粹运动分裂成了各种派系，有时是相互交战的派系。希特勒所做的是将这些派系重新聚集在一起，巩固它们。
on the extreme radical racialist right. Of course, it's only one stream in German politics, not the key theme even, but it became much more popular after the First World War. So Hitler's one exponent of that. And later on, and I'd say the re-founding of the Nazi party in 1925 was one of those moments, Hitler becomes then an irreplaceable element because the Nazi movement, like practically all fascist movements, actually, wherever you look at them, is susceptible, was susceptible to a lot of factionalism and breakaways. And you saw this when Hitler was for several months imprisoned in 1924, that the Nazi movement, which had been banned, just broke apart into various factions, sometimes warring factions. What Hitler did was to bring these together again, to cement them.
从那时起，将其视为一个与希特勒捆绑在一起的领袖政党的概念就是一个关键因素。从那时起，希特勒的角色变得越来越核心。回答你提出的第二个问题，如果没有希特勒会发生什么？嗯，有些事情会发生，比如极端民族主义的倾向，一旦进入30年代，就会出现对《凡尔赛条约》的修正。这些事情在任何民族主义政府下都会发生。
And from then onwards, the notion of this as a leader party bound to Hitler was a crucial factor. And from there onwards, Hitler's role becomes more and more central. And to answer the second, I think, question that you posed there, what is to happen without Hitler? Well, certain things would have done, the tendency towards extreme nationalism and once you're into the 1930s, then towards a revision of Versailles. Those sort of things would have happened with any nationalist government.
但其他事情如果没有希特勒就不会发生。因此，我认为你可以说，在20世纪20年代中期以后的发展背景下，希特勒的角色是绝对核心的，并且变得更加核心。那么，个人的作用就变得至关重要了，因为你刚才说，如果没有希特勒，是否会如此迅速地陷入一个法治被完全抛弃的警察国家，如果没有希特勒，是否会有如此重大的欧洲战争？有可能，但可能不会。即使是第三帝国的二号人物赫尔曼·戈林，到1939年也想阻止这一点，想让希特勒避开他正在冒的风险。第三，如果没有希特勒，我们会有大屠杀吗？
But other things would not have happened without Hitler. And I think you can therefore say that in the context as it developed from the mid-1920s onwards, Hitler's role was absolutely central and became even more central. So the role of the individual then becomes crucial because of you then said without Hitler would there have been such a rapid descent into a police state in which the rules of law were completely discarded, such a a major European war without Hitler? Potentially, but probably not. Even Hermann Goering, the second man in the Third Reich, then wanted to prevent that by 1939, wanted to head Hitler off from the risk he was taking. And thirdly, would we have had the Holocaust without Hitler?
毫无疑问，会有反犹太主义，会有反犹太立法。但如果没有希特勒，我们会有大屠杀吗？我会说不会。所以没有希特勒，就没有大屠杀。因此，希特勒确实成为了这些发展的核心，尽管他在最初的几年里，
There would have been anti-Semitism, anti-Semitic legislation, unquestionably. But without Hitler, would we have had a Holocaust? I would say no. So no Hitler, no Holocaust. So Hitler does become central to these developments, yet he's nonetheless initially in the first years, in particular,
只是德国极右翼中普遍存在的更广泛趋势的倡导者。伊恩，我知道汤姆想在稍后回来讨论大屠杀，但在我们这样做之前，希特勒显然有一种作为伟人的自我意识。他读过托马斯·卡莱尔，或者他有托马斯·卡莱尔关于腓特烈大帝的书，我想没错吧？希特勒在某种程度上是“伟人史观”的最后堡垒之一吗？即一个个体塑造了国家进程，数百万人的生命取决于这个人在他的巢穴中所做的决定？还是说这比那更复杂？正如你所想象的那样，这比那更复杂，正如你所想象的那样，这比那更复杂
just an exponent of wider trends which were prevalent on the German extreme right. Ian, I know Tom wants to come back about the Holocaust in a second, but just before we do that, Hitler obviously had a sense of himself as a great man. He read Thomas Carlyle, or he had Thomas Carlyle's book on Frederick the Great, I think, didn't he? And is Hitler, to some extent, one of the last redoubts of great man history, an individual shaping the course of nations, the lives of millions, depending on the decisions taken by this one man in his kind of lair? Or is it more complicated than that? As you might imagine, it it more complicated than that as you might imagine it's more complicated
……但首先，伟人理论，我认为这根本带不来什么……作为一种历史理论，它最好被摒弃。事实上，我会摒弃历史伟大性、伟大个人的概念，所以我认为暗示某人是伟大的并没有什么意义……因为没有衡量标准。我们可能会说，因为我们有一些审美标准，莫扎特是一位伟大的作曲家；我们可能会说布拉德曼是一位伟大的击球手。但我认为当你谈到政治家时，“伟大”这个词很快就会瓦解，你无法准确定义它。所以如果你说“伟大”意味着“道德上可接受”，
than that um but it it's uh first of all the great man theory i i i think that's that takes us nowhere really um as a theory of history it's best discarded in fact i would discard the notion of greatness historical greatness of great individuals so I think there's not much point in in suggesting that x y or z was great um because there's no there are no criteria for that we might say uh because we have some aesthetic measurements that Mozart was a great composer um we might say that Bradman was a great batsman but But I think when you come to politicians, it has the term great rapidly disintegrates and you can't define it properly. So if you say great meaning morally acceptable,
那么没有哪位政治领袖是完全道德上可接受的。但显然他们中的许多人在道德上是不可接受的，但他们却产生了巨大的影响。所以我认为我们在这里寻找的是个人的影响，而不是个人的伟大。希特勒确实产生了巨大的影响。这就是我们需要评估的内容。然后我们必须审视任何个人——不仅仅是希特勒——能够发挥如此重要作用的背景。然后你就会进入那些超越该个人的力量，这些力量使该个人首先能够掌权，
then there's no political leader who is entirely morally acceptable. But obviously many of them are morally unacceptable, but they have an enormous impact. So I think it's the work that we're looking for here is the impact of an individual, not personal greatness. And Hitler certainly had a colossal impact. And that's what we need to be assessing. And then we have to look at the context within which any individual, not just Hitler, can play such a significant role. And that you then into the forces which which go beyond that individual that enable that individual to come to power in
并决定了该个人产生如此巨大影响的能力，这些才是我们必须问的关键问题。实际上，首先将某人推上权力的权力框架，无论是希特勒、列宁还是其他任何人，以及他们能够行使权力的条件。这些才是关键问题，而不是个人的伟大。但我猜希特勒与列宁或希特勒与斯大林之间的对比在于，对于列宁和斯大林来说，他们将自己塑造为浩瀚力量的代理人。从某种意义上说，无产阶级是他们故事中的英雄。而希特勒则绝对突出了英雄个人挺身而出并塑造国家命运的观念。
the first place and then condition the capability of that individual to have such an enormous impact and those are the key questions that we have to ask actually the framework of power which brings somebody to power in the first place, whether it's Hitler or whether it's Lenin or whoever it might be, and then the conditions with which they're able to exercise that power. Those are the key questions, not the greatness of the individual. But I guess a contrast between Hitler and Lenin or Hitler and Stalin, is that for Lenin and Stalin, they cast themselves as agents of vast forces. And in a sense, it's the proletariat who are the heroes of their story. Whereas Hitler is absolutely foregrounding the idea that heroic individuals step forward and shape the destiny of
你认为希特勒对那种历史理解以及伟人所扮演角色的信念，是否影响了他最终所扮演的角色，即他最终投射到全世界的那种可怕的、泰坦般的阴影？是的，我确实这么认为。我认为这是一个非常好且中肯的观点。它逐渐将他塑造为一个强大的领袖，
nations. And do you think that Hitler's belief in that kind of understanding of history and the role that great men play impacted on the role that he did indeed end up playing, this kind of monstrous, titanic shadow that he ended up casting over the whole world? Yes, I do. I think that's a very good and fair point. It gradually frames him, I do. I think that's a very good and fair point. It gradually frames him, I think, as a powerful leader,
因为起初他根本不把自己看作那样的人，他认为自己是在为德国即将到来的领袖铺平道路。但在1923年底政变失败后，他确实开始将自己视为德国等待中的伟大领袖，那种个人命运、伟大性的感觉确实在他掌权后的崛起中发挥了作用。当我多年前写一本名为《希特勒神话》的书时，我抓住了1936年莱茵兰军事化这一点，希特勒当时开始以某种方式相信自己的神话，他说：“我以梦游者般的确定性走我的路。”那对我来说似乎是他开始相信自己绝对正确的那一刻，那种伟大和命运的感觉确实发挥了作用。他在1939年向将军们解释发动战争的必要性时也这么说。他说，我随时可能被暗杀。而我在其中的角色是不可或缺的。在某种程度上，到1939年他是对的。但关于这一点还有一个更广泛的
because initially he doesn't see himself as that at all, but he sees himself as paving the way for Germany's leader to come. But after the failure of the putsch at the end of 1923, he does start to see himself in that role as germany's great leader in waiting and the the sense of personal uh personal destiny of being of greatness then does play a part in in his uh in his ascendance in particular when he's in power and when i wrote a book many years ago called the hitler myth i seized upon the point uh of the uh the um military remilitarization of the rhineland in 1936 where hitler then starts to believe in his own myth somehow then and he says i go my way with the with the certainty
观点，希特勒并不是当时唯一一个相信自己有命运感的人。墨索里尼也是，丘吉尔也是，戴高乐也是。所以对于这些19世纪末的产物来说，个人命运的概念影响了他们所有人。但正如你所说，希特勒是以一种相当极端的方式。你谈到了“伟大”这个概念是多么困难、多么棘手，在你看来，我想是多么无用。但人们应用在希特勒身上最多的那个词呢？
of a sleepwalker and that seemed to me to be the one moment where he starts believing in his own infallibility and that the sense of greatness and destiny then does play a part. And he says that in 1939, that when he is explained to his generals, the need to go to war then. And he says that any moment I could be assassinated. And my role in this is indispensable. And to a certain extent, he was right in that by 1939. But there's one wider
如果你在对话中，或者说在公共话语中，悬在希特勒头上的词是“邪恶”。作为一名历史学家，这是否……好吧，我明白它不一定有用，但你能逃避它吗？你能写一本关于希特勒的书，而不带有一种压倒性的意识，即他已经成为人类邪恶最纯粹形式的代表吗？
point on this is Hitler wasn't the only one at the time who believed in the sense of destiny for himself. Mussolini did too. Churchill did. de Gaulle did. So for these people who were products of the late 19th century, the notion of personal destiny was something which affected all of them. But Hitler in quite an extreme fashion, as you say. You've talked about how kind of difficult and how thorny, and in your view, sort of useless, I guess, the idea of greatness is. But what about the other thing that people, I mean, the thing that people apply to Hitler more than anything else?
嗯，我认为所有的历史学家，我们都必须使用语言，而语言本身就背叛了我们的许多想法。这是不可避免的。我们做不到。我们无法避免。但正如你在问题中所暗示的那样，“邪恶”这个词，如果你在谈论希特勒，当然，你会说他可能是20世纪最邪恶的人之一，或者谈论他时，“邪恶”很快就会浮现在脑海中。但在写传记时，我决定从一开始就摒弃这个词，就像摒弃任何关于伟大性的概念一样，因为它不是一个有用的分析术语。我的意思是，如果你说“希特勒是邪恶的缩影”，它真的解释了什么吗？
If you're in conversation, as it were, sort of public discourse, the word that hangs over Hitler is evil. As a historian, is that at all... Well, I can see that it's not necessarily useful, but can you escape from it? Can you write a book about Hitler without this sort of overpowering consciousness that he has come to represent sort of human wickedness in its most distilled form?
我的意思是，解释为什么数百万德国人实际上愿意支持他、为他欢呼、为他投票等等。它能解释他所做的决定吗？它只是一个没有用的分析术语。这是一个形而上学的术语，而不是历史分析术语。但是，当然，正如我所说，在写作中，我们无法……思考某个人时，你实际上无法逃避它。你看看像……我知道我们会回到
Well, I think all historians, we all have to use language, and the language itself betrays many of our thoughts. That's inescapable. We can't do that. We can't avoid that. But the term evil, as you're implying in your question there, is something which if you're in a conversation about Hitler, of course, you would say is possibly one of the most evil men of the 20th century, or evil comes rapidly to mind in talking about him anyway. But when I was writing the biography, I decided right at the beginning to discard that term as well as discard any sort of notion of greatness, because it's not a useful analytical term. I mean, if you say, well, Hitler was the epitome of evil, does it actually explain very much?
大屠杀，但如果你在谈论大屠杀，那么很难逃避这样一个概念：这是20世纪最大的罪行。而对此负有最大责任的人就是希特勒。所以那种巨大的邪恶感在某种程度上显然是无法与希特勒剥离的。但仅仅在分析他所做的事情时，它并不是很有用。它会占据主导地位，我的意思是，我在节目开头说过，当你做一期关于希特勒的节目时，你也在做一期关于如何书写历史的节目。是的，整个过程是必须的。我的意思是，你对此有同样的感受吗？我的意思是，你有你个人的偏见、直觉和态度，但是……我的意思是，你必须保持它们，你必须在写作时筛选它们。
I mean, explain why millions of Germans actually were ready to support him and cheer for him and vote for him and things. And does it explain the decisions that he was making? It's just not a useful analytical term. It's a metaphysical term, not a historical analytical term. But, of course, we are, as I said, in writing, we can't, thinking about an individual, you can't actually escape it. And you look at something like, I know we're going to come back
你必须。我想你……这是一个有趣的问题，不是吗？听伊恩爵士谈论希特勒，因为当我在写……你知道，人们对撒切尔夫人有……是的，有极其强烈的观点……几乎一样邪恶。我的意思是，不是人们，所以……
to the Holocaust, but if you're talking about the Holocaust, then it's difficult to escape the notion that this is the greatest crime of the 20th century. And the man who was more than any other responsible for that was Hitler. So the sense of great evil then obviously is in one way inescapable from Hitler. But just in analysing what he did, it's not very useful it will dominate i mean i said at the the top of the show that um when you do an episode on hitler you're also kind of doing an episode on how you write history yeah the whole process is it required i mean do you feel the same about that i mean this is kind of you have your well i know that you have your personal prejudices and instincts and uh attitudes but um i mean you have to keep them you have to kind of winnow them when you write.
嗯，有些人会这么认为。我的意思是，这很奇怪，不是吗？但你是对的，汤姆。我认为在某种程度上，你必须非常清楚自己的偏见，我认为，还有你自己的感受。但你必须尝试超越它们。我的意思是，这就是历史学术和历史训练的意义所在，即你有时可以跳出自己的偏好和先入之见。但当然，让我把它转回给你。当你写古代世界或中世纪时期的暴行时，你是否必须克制住自己的个人反感之类的？我的意思是，如果这只是一种持续的哀叹，那将是一本非常无聊的书，不是吗？
You do. I suppose you – it's an interesting one, isn't it, listening to Sir Ian talking about Hitler, because when I'm writing about, you know, people have – Thatcher. Yeah, incredibly strong opinions about – Almost as evil. I mean, not people, so –
我认为这是一个有趣的问题，我相信我们稍后会在节目中谈到，希特勒离我们太近了，而发生在遥远过去的事情看起来可能很遥远。所以几乎是相反的，当你写凯撒和高卢人，或者像我们之前谈过的尼禄和斯波鲁斯时。你必须提醒自己，这些不仅仅是神话中的人物。这些是……你知道，这些事情发生在真实的人身上，你知道。但这显然不是希特勒的问题。我们将回来讨论，好吧，真正讨论希特勒是如何成为希特勒的。我们将在休息后讨论他的早年生活。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
Well, some people would. I mean, that's the weird thing, isn't it? But you're right, Tom. I think to some extent you have to be very aware of your own prejudice, I think, and your own feelings. But you have to try and transcend them. I mean, that's what historical scholarship and historical training is meant to be all about, that you can sometimes step outside your own predilections and your own preconceptions. But also, surely, let me turn it back to you. When you're writing about atrocities in the classical world or the medieval period or something, do you have to sort of bite back your own personal revulsion or whatever? I mean, if it's just a kind of constant lament, that'd be a very boring book, wouldn't it?
欢迎回到《历史的余味》，我们和英国最伟大的在世历史学家之一伊恩·克肖爵士在一起，我们正在谈论他的伟大主题——希特勒。汤姆，我想你想问关于书写希特勒纳粹前生活困难的问题，对吧？是的。所以如果我们看一些希特勒的传记，当你写传记时，从某种意义上说，这是一个目的论的过程。你对结局有一种感觉，这种生活将导致什么，它将产生什么结果。如果你说“没有希特勒，就没有大屠杀”，那么因为这个人而导致600万人死亡的阴影，本质上就笼罩在你将要书写的生命之上。所以，我再次确信这是一个幼稚的问题，但我忍不住要问。所以当你审视希特勒的开端时，
I think it's an interesting question, and I'm sure it's one we'll come on to later in the show that um hitler is so is so close to us whereas things that happened in in the distant past it can seem distant so almost it's the opposite almost when you're writing about caesar and the ghouls or say nero and sporus you know we've talked about before. You have to remind yourselves that these are not just figures of myth. These are figures, you know, these things happen to real people, you know. But that's never, you know, that's obviously not an issue with Hitler. And we will be coming back and we will be talking about, well, really how Hitler became Hitler. We'll be talking about his early years after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. well, really how Hitler became Hitler. We'll be talking about his early years after the break. launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com
他的祖先、他的祖父、他的祖父母、他的父母、他的童年，有什么东西可以作为警告信号，引起对它最终结局的警觉吗？还是说问这个问题本身就很幼稚？不，你的问题从来都不幼稚，汤姆。但这些问题作为历史学家，在撰写生平总结时必须放在脑后。显然，我们知道这个故事的终点，地堡里的死亡。我们知道大屠杀等等。但在撰写一本有价值的传记时，无论是关于希特勒还是其他人，
welcome back to the rest is history we are with sir ian kershaw one of britain's greatest living historians and we are talking about um his great subject, Hitler. And Tom, I think you wanted to ask about the difficulty of writing about Hitler's life before Nazism, didn't you? Yeah. So if we look at some of the biography of Hitler, but when you write a biography, in a sense, it's a teleological process. You have a sense of the end, where this life is going to lead to, what it's going to result in. And if you're saying, no Hitler, no Holocaust, then this shadow of 6 million people dead because of this one man, essentially, hangs over the life that you're going to write. So again, I'm sure it's a naive question, but it's one that I can't help but ask. So when you look at the beginnings of Hitler,
一个人必须回到起点，试图解释这些事情是如何发生的，而不是直接使用终点作为解释本身。例如，审视希特勒的童年，我们必须摆脱这样一种观念：这是一个后来做了可怕事情的人。事实上，即使在传记中，在某个时刻，我记得我确实说过，如果你看希特勒的童年，你甚至可能会说，这是一个来自非常动荡家庭背景的人。你甚至可能对他有一些同情。当然，你不会在孩子身上看到我们正在处理的后来的怪物，如果这是处理它的正确方式的话，
his ancestry, his grandfather, his grandparents, his parents, his childhood, is there anything there that serves as a warning flag, raises alarms about where it's going to end up? Or is it naive even to ask that question? No, your questions are never naive, Tom. But they are questions that, as a historian, one has to put at the back of one's mind when writing the life summary. Obviously, we know the end point of this story, the death in the bunker. We know about the Holocaust and so on. But in actually writing a worthwhile biography, whether it's of Hitler or anybody else,
在20世纪40年代。关于大屠杀，我在书中以及我的其他著作中特别强调了试图解释这个过程，即它发生的漫长过程，而不是仅仅通过某种希特勒的偏执狂来看待它，这种偏执狂不可避免地导致大屠杀作为终点。所以我们必须避免那种目的论，无论是个人还是社会过程。因为它几乎变成了一种安慰，不是吗？那种认为你可以解释希特勒所做的事情，比如，你发现了一些核心心理缺陷的想法。所以人们经常谈论，希特勒的祖父是犹太人吗？这是他担心的事情吗之类的？这很简单。不，他不是。是的。
one has to go back to the beginning and try to explain how these things take place without actually using the end point as an explanation in itself. So looking at Hitler's childhood, for example, we have to escape from the notion that this was a man who did terrible things later on. And in fact, even in the biography, at some point, as I recall, I did say that if you look at Hitler's childhood, you might actually even say, well, here's somebody from a very disturbed family background. You might even have some sympathy for him. Certainly, you don't see in the child, the later monster that we're dealing with, if that's the right way to put
好的。所以答案是祖父不是犹太人，希特勒也不担心这一点。所以作为一个想法，那是胡说八道。没错，我认为这些心理学理论最好以一种非常批判和保守的方式对待，也就是说，再次……对于任何传记作者来说，采用通常无法证明的心理学理论是一个简单的操作，因为当事人甚至从未躺在心理学家的沙发上。然后将其解读为一种完整、错综复杂且复杂的历史发展。
it, in the 1940s. And as regards the Holocaust, made a particular point in the book, as in other writings of mine, of trying to explain the process, the lengthy process by which this came about, rather than seeing it through just through some Hitler paranoia, which then inevitably leads to the Holocaust as the final point. So we have to avoid that teleology, whether it's personal or it's social in its processes. Because it becomes almost a kind of comfort, doesn't it? The idea that you can explain what Hitler does, say, you come across some core psychological flaw. So people often talk about, was Hitler's grandfather a Jew? Was this something that he worried about or something like that? That's easy. No, he wasn't. Yeah.
我尽力在传记中避免这种情况，并将关于希特勒的各种心理理论主要放在脚注中，而不是正文中。对于这些想法，无论是希特勒还是其他任何人，我从来没有遇到过太大的麻烦。所以我认为我们必须处理的是解释这些事情的政治过程，而不是心理障碍。伊恩，我可以问一个听起来很平凡的问题吗？
Okay. So the answer to that is that the grandfather wasn't Jewish and Hitler didn't worry about that. So that as an idea is a nonsense. That's right i think these these psychological theories are best treated in a very critical and conservative fashion that is to say that again um it's it's an easy uh operation for any biographer to take up psychological theories which are usually non-provable because the subject has never been on a psychologist's couch even. And then read into that an entire intricate and complex historical development.
你认为希特勒在什么时候成为了希特勒？那么阿道夫·希特勒，阿道夫·希特勒这个人是在什么时候变成了我们现在所看到的这种——我不知道正确的词是什么——受损的、情感上……不仅是不敏感，而且是暴力和破坏性的？在什么时候……当他在第一次世界大战前贫穷而悲惨时，然后当他是艺术家时，他们称他为艺术家，不是吗，或者在战壕里时，他似乎不是20世纪20年代和30年代那种恶魔般的人物。
And I tried my best in the biography to avoid that and discarded the various psycho theories of Hitler, mainly in footnotes rather than in the text itself. And I've never had very much trouble with those ideas, whether it's Hitler or anybody else for that matter. So I think what we have to deal with are political processes that explain these things rather than psychological hang-ups. Ian, can I ask sort of what might sound a very mundane question?
你认为他在什么时候发生了那种转变？或者说没有一个他以那种方式转变的时刻？我认为关键点，关键时期，无论如何，这不是一个绝对精确的点，但关键时期是……在第一次世界大战后立即的慕尼黑时期，我认为正如当时一位德国历史学家所说的那样，政治找到了希特勒，而不是希特勒找到了政治。我们处于一战后慕尼黑的条件下。希特勒随后明显变成了我们后来所知的希特勒。所以我认为是在1919年的那几个月里，我们真正认出了他，当然，这在传记上关于他是一个引人入胜的事情，因为对于……出生于1889年，所以从1889年到1919年，他是一个完全
At what point would you say Hitler became Hitler? So Adolf Hitler, at what point did Adolf Hitler the man become what we would now see as this, I don't know what the right words are, damaged, emotionally sort of, not just insensitive, but violent and destructive. At what point does, you know,, when he's sort of poor and miserable before the First World War, and then when he's the artist, they call him the artist, don't they, or something in the trenches, he doesn't seem to be the sort of demonic figure of the 1920s and 1930s.
无足轻重、默默无闻的人，我们几乎对他一无所知，他完全不重要，他所说的任何话都没有被周围的任何人感兴趣，被周围的任何人视为有任何兴趣。然后从1919年开始，他成为了一个帮助引发世界大战、种族灭绝并摧毁自己国家的人。所以这是一个惊人的轨迹，但它确实，关键时期，
At what point do you think he did sort of shift? Or was there not a point when he shifted in that way i think the key point the key um period at any rate it's not an absolute precise point but the key period is um in munich in the period immediately following the first world war and that's i think where as one historian German historian put it at the time, where politics came to Hitler, Hitler didn't come to politics. And we're in the conditions that follow the First War in Munich. Hitler then becomes visibly the sort of Hitler that we know subsequently. So I think it's in those months of 1919 that we really recognize and that's a an intriguing thing about him biographically of course that for the um as born in 1889 so between 1889 and 1919 he's he's somebody who is completely
你认为他在哪个时间点发生了转变？还是说他并没有一个明确的转变节点？我认为关键点，或者说关键时期，虽然不是一个绝对精确的时间点，但关键时期是在第一次世界大战结束后的慕尼黑。正如当时一位德国历史学家所言，是政治找到了希特勒，而不是希特勒投身了政治。在第一次世界大战后慕尼黑的社会环境下，希特勒开始显露出我们后来所熟知的那种形象。所以我认为正是1919年的那几个月，我们真正认出了他。当然，从传记的角度来看，这非常引人入胜，因为他出生于1889年，所以在1889年到1919年之间，他是一个完全
inconsequential anonymous we hardly know anything about him really he's totally unimportant nothing he says is taken of any interest by anybody around him, seen as any interest by anybody around him. And then from 1919 onwards, he's somebody who helps to bring about world war, genocide and destroy his own country. So it's a phenomenal trajectory, but it really, the key period,
无足轻重、默默无闻的人，我们几乎对他一无所知。他完全不重要，他所说的一切在周围人眼中都毫无意义，没人对他感兴趣。然而从1919年开始，他却成为了引发世界大战、种族灭绝并摧毁自己国家的人。这是一个惊人的轨迹，但确实，关键时期就在于此。
I think is between 1919 and 1923. And the months of 1919 are the period where I think, if we want to be precise, we can say that's when Hitler becomes Hitler. And what is it that happens then? What is it? What is the spark? What happens then is that he, and incidentally, Hitler is very quiet in Mein Kampf and anything else that he wrote or said about these precise months. But between the revolution in Germany in 1918 and the spring of 1919, Hitler was living in Munich, experiencing a socialist revolution, then experiencing the key moment probably in March and April 1919, the so-called Councils Republic, where Munich was taken over by extreme left-wing revolutionary movement, which attempted to build up councils in the way that Soviets, the German words, Russian words, Soviets, just another word for council.
我认为是在1919年到1923年之间。1919年的那几个月，如果我们要精确一点的话，可以说那是希特勒成为希特勒的时期。当时发生了什么？到底是什么？导火索是什么？当时发生的事情是，顺便说一下，希特勒在《我的奋斗》以及他所写或所说的任何关于这几个月的内容中都非常沉默。但在1918年德国革命和1919年春天之间，希特勒住在慕尼黑，经历了社会主义革命，然后经历了可能是在1919年3月和4月的关键时刻，即所谓的“苏维埃共和国”，当时慕尼黑被极左翼革命运动接管，他们试图以苏维埃的方式建立委员会，德语词汇、俄语词汇，苏维埃，其实就是委员会的另一个说法。
So Russian-style Soviets, which, and there are a large number in the leadership of the Soviets in Munich in April 1919, were a considerable number of Jews, some of them of foreign origin. And Hitler was at that time in the barracks in Munich, and he was even elected to be a representative of the barracks. And therefore, in a way, he had to be then somebody on the left or seen to be on the left at that time to be elected as a council, as a representative of these barracks in this time. But immediately after the collapse of this, when it was destroyed by right-wing troops coming in
所以是俄式苏维埃，在1919年4月慕尼黑苏维埃的领导层中，有大量犹太人，其中一些是外籍人士。希特勒当时在慕尼黑的军营里，他甚至被选为军营的代表。因此，在某种程度上，他当时必须表现得像个左派，或者看起来是左派，才能在那个时期被选为这些军营的代表。但在这一切崩溃之后，当它被进城的右翼军队摧毁时，
and pulling it down with great ferocity, Hitler then, within his own barracks then, becomes a figure who is like a turncoat, so he's now actually denouncing people in his barracks and elsewhere who then took part in this council's movements. And that's the key moment, I think, where Hitler then becomes converted. After that, then, in the army, then in the army still in the army he becomes then seen as somebody
并以极大的凶猛将其镇压，希特勒在自己的军营里变成了一个像变节者一样的人物，他现在实际上是在谴责他军营里和其他地方参与了这场委员会运动的人。我认为这是关键时刻，希特勒从此被“转化”了。在那之后，在军队里，他仍然在军队里，他开始被视为某个人，
who is can by September 1919 be writing a tract seen as a somehow as a specialist on the Jewish question where he can write a letter in answer to an inquiry to come in and saying that the future has to be built upon the removal or any nationalist nationalist government would aim to remove the Jews altogether. And in September 1919, he joins the infant German Workers' Party, which was called later the Nazi Party. And in that summer months of 1919, he's sent on to indoctrinate troops who are waiting for demobilisation. And he learns at that time, as he puts it in Mein Kampf, he learns that he could speak. That is to say that people were listening to his message
到了1919年9月，他已经可以写出一份被视为某种犹太问题专家的传单，他可以在回复询问时写信说，未来必须建立在清除犹太人的基础上，或者任何民族主义政府的目标都是彻底清除犹太人。1919年9月，他加入了初创的德国工人党，也就是后来所谓的纳粹党。在1919年的那个夏天，他被派去向等待复员的部队进行灌输。他在那时学到，正如他在《我的奋斗》中所说，他学会了演讲。也就是说，人们在听他的信息，
and they were enthused by it. And he came across then as an archetypal anti-Semitic firebrand, which was enthusing the troops who were already open to these messages in the barracks. So that's a peer which was absolutely crucial in the troops who were already open to these messages in the barracks. So that's a period which was absolutely crucial in Hitler's own personal development. And by September 1919, when he's joining the infant Nazi party, still in the army, he then is visibly then somebody who is prepared now to engage in right-wing, radical, extreme, racist politics. And we had a lot of questions about this sort of period and about this issue.
并且被它所鼓舞。他当时表现得像一个典型的反犹太煽动者，这让军营里本来就对这些信息持开放态度的士兵们感到振奋。所以这是一个对希特勒个人发展绝对关键的时期。到了1919年9月，当他加入初创的纳粹党时，他仍然在军队里，他已经明显是一个准备好参与右翼、激进、极端、种族主义政治的人了。我们关于这个时期和这个问题有很多疑问。
Because, I mean, you've famously called Hitler a non-person. And the first part of your biography shows so convincingly that Hitler, for the first 30 years of his life, he's a nobody. He is a pitiful figure, really. He's a loser. He's one of life's losers. And then he discovers, I mean, what you could call, if you were being trite, he discovers his superpower.
因为，我的意思是，你曾著名地称希特勒为一个“非人”。你的传记的第一部分非常有说服力地展示了希特勒在他生命的前30年里，他是一个无名小卒。他确实是一个可怜的人物。他是一个失败者。他是生活中的失败者之一。然后他发现，我的意思是，如果你说得平庸一点，你可以称之为他发现了他的“超能力”。
And we had tons of questions about this. So, for example, Andrew Kelman asks, you know, if he's so useless, what talents did he possess? And is it just speaking, rhetorical ability, or is there something more? Wherein lies his charisma, if you like you know wherein lies his charisma if you like wherein lies his charisma that's a big question but um in terms of his abilities um he in this period i'm just talking about now as he said it twice in mein kampf um i then i i realized i could
我们收到了大量关于这个问题的问题。例如，安德鲁·凯尔曼问，如果他这么没用，他有什么天赋？仅仅是演讲、修辞能力，还是有更多的东西？他的魅力在于哪里，如果你愿意的话，他的魅力在于哪里，这是一个大问题，但嗯，就他的能力而言，嗯，他在我刚才谈到的这个时期，正如他在《我的奋斗》中两次提到的那样，我当时意识到我可以
speak and for the first time people were listening him, which says something about the way in which German mentality as a general politics had shifted in the immediate post-war period. So before the First World War, these views were those of an extreme minority, which were not, would have been, Hitler would have made no mark at all then. People would have been seeing him. And he actually didn't have these views until the immediate period so what he had was he learned that he had this ability to reach an audience with his rhetoric it was he became then aware of his own demagogic talents
演讲，这是第一次有人在听他说话，这说明了德国人的心态作为一种普遍的政治在战后初期发生了怎样的转变。所以在一战之前，这些观点只是极端少数派的观点，如果是在那时，希特勒根本不会留下任何印记。人们会看着他。而且他实际上在那个时期之前并没有这些观点，所以他所拥有的是他学会了这种用修辞触动听众的能力，他开始意识到自己煽动性的天赋，
but these demagogic talents were real ones because he spoke from the heart. It wasn't contrived. He felt like this. He felt an intense anger and resentment and hatred of those people who he thought had done Germany down towards the end of the First World War. So that period towards the end of the First World War and into the revolution and through the revolution and out at the other side of it was the period that was really crucial for him because always whatever inbuilt hatreds he'd had of a personal kind before, then became turned into a sort of worldview, as he put it, an ideology.
但这些煽动性的天赋是真实的，因为他是发自内心地说话。这不是虚构的。他确实有这种感觉。他对自己认为在一战末期出卖了德国的那些人感到强烈的愤怒、怨恨和仇恨。所以那一时期，从一战末期到革命，再到革命过程中以及走出革命的另一面，对他来说确实是至关重要的时期，因为无论他之前有什么内在的个人仇恨，在那时都变成了一种世界观，正如他所说的，一种意识形态。
And the focus upon Jews was the central point of this, but he was a German, extreme German nationalist. And what he was wanting to do then, in the Munich beer halls, was to pour out his bile on the politicians who he felt had sold Germany down the river. And this is the message that he got across. And the more he got the message across, the more it had a resonance within himself. So he saw himself then increasingly as a figure who could do this. But he called himself for some years in the early 1920s, the drummer, and was seen as the drummer up of support for the great leader who was going to come. And only from 1923, 24 onwards, did he come to see himself as that leader himself.
而对犹太人的关注是其中的核心点，但他是一个德国人，极端的德国民族主义者。他当时在慕尼黑啤酒馆里想做的是，向那些他认为出卖了德国的政客们倾泻他的愤怒。这就是他传达的信息。他传达的信息越多，它在他自己内心产生的共鸣就越强。所以他越来越把自己看作是一个能做到这一点的人。但在20世纪20年代初的几年里，他称自己为“鼓手”，被视为为即将到来的伟大领袖敲鼓助威的人。直到1923、24年之后，他才开始把自己视为那个领袖本人。
And once there, you're into the building up then of a sense of charisma. Charisma then is a manufactured product. It's not something that an individual has innately, but rather something that the people around him see in him. And that people were portraying this on Hitler and saying that he's Germany's Mussolini. That went to his head as well. So immediately following Mussolini's takeover in Italy in 1922, in the beer halls of Munich, people said, we've got our own Mussolini here. Those things to a character like Hitler, who was so aware of his own fanatical ideas already,
一旦到了那个位置，你就开始建立一种魅力感。魅力是一种制造出来的产品。它不是一个人天生就有的东西，而是周围的人在他身上看到的东西。人们把这种魅力投射到希特勒身上，说他是德国的墨索里尼。这也冲昏了他的头脑。所以紧随1922年墨索里尼在意大利夺权之后，在慕尼黑的啤酒馆里，人们说，我们这里也有自己的墨索里尼。对于像希特勒这样已经意识到自己狂热思想的性格来说，这些事情，
this went to his head too. So he started to see himself in this way and others saw him more and more in that way too. This process by which John the Baptist decides that, well, actually I'm Jesus. I'm going to be the Messiah. It does seem to align with the fact that his talent is for demagoguery, because we see it now with the process of radicalization, that the more you talk about something, and the more you get an audience, and the more the audience enthuse you, do you think? Do you think he becomes progressively, say, more anti-Semitic, more hostile to the people that he privately disliked through the process of articulating it and seeing people enthused by what he's saying to them?
这也冲昏了他的头脑。所以他开始以这种方式看待自己，别人也越来越多地以这种方式看待他。这种“施洗约翰决定自己其实是耶稣，我要成为弥赛亚”的过程，似乎与他的天赋在于煽动性相吻合，因为我们现在在激进化过程中看到了这一点，你谈论某件事越多，你得到的听众越多，听众越是鼓舞你，你认为呢？你认为他是否通过表达这些观点并看到人们被他的话所鼓舞的过程，变得越来越反犹太，对那些他私下不喜欢的人越来越敌视？
I think it certainly reinforces the views that he had, but I think he had those views fairly consistently from 1919 right through to the end and that period of once hitler's sort of character that once he developed an idea a fixated idea he never moved away from it and those ideas were i think already fixed with him by the by 1919 or afterwards and then come to the reinforcement of those ideas through exactly what you're saying, through the appeal that he found, he could instill in other people through his harangues in the Munich beer halls and the rest of it.
我认为这肯定加强了他已有的观点，但我认为他从1919年到最后一直相当一致地持有这些观点，一旦希特勒的性格形成了一种固定的想法，他就从未动摇过。我认为这些想法在1919年或之后就已经在他心中固定下来了，然后通过你所说的，通过他在慕尼黑啤酒馆的演说以及其他方式在其他人身上灌输的吸引力，这些想法得到了加强。
So it's a two-way process there. But certainly the response he was getting in Munich shored up the feelings that he was right. One other thing that I'll just add to that, though, is that he wasn't just a demagogue. And he had very good tactical acumen, in particular for the weaknesses of his opponents. And he shows that already from the mid-1920s onwards. And increasingly, his time was thrown later on, of course, with foreign opponents as well. He's got a very sure notion of the weaknesses of his opponents and goes for the juggler role. And his astuteness in that is something that everybody underestimated right the way through. Just one obvious, I guess it's the huge question around, you know, Hitler had his ideas right from the beginning. Did he have the idea
所以这是一个双向的过程。但他在慕尼黑得到的反应肯定巩固了他认为自己是正确的这种感觉。不过，我还要补充一点，他不仅仅是一个煽动者。他有非常好的战术敏锐度，特别是针对对手的弱点。他从20世纪20年代中期开始就已经表现出来了。而且随着时间的推移，后来当然也包括外国对手。他对自己对手的弱点有非常确切的认识，并直击要害。他在这一点上的精明是所有人一直以来都低估的。只是一个显而易见的问题，我想这是关于“希特勒从一开始就有他的想法”这个巨大问题，他有那个想法吗？
of the final solution? When did he arrive at that? No. No. And just one word of caution on, he had these ideas from the very beginning. No, his ideas changed. So for example, although antisemitism was a central feature, hatred of Jews is a better term probably for it. Hatred of Jews was central to his thinking from, as I said, from 1919 onwards as an ideological explanation. It's a process itself, which doubtlessly was anti-Semitic to some extent already in Vienna. But the real key period was then the early 1920s when it becomes an ideology for him. But one other point, for example, the Lebensraum or the living space idea, that comes somewhat later. Also, the anti-Bolshevism isn't there initially. It's more anti-capitalism with anti-Semitism
关于“最终解决方案”？他是什么时候得出的？没有。没有。关于“他从一开始就有这些想法”这一点，要提醒一下。不，他的想法变了。例如，虽然反犹太主义是一个核心特征，但“仇恨犹太人”可能是一个更好的术语。正如我所说，从1919年起，仇恨犹太人作为一种意识形态解释，一直是他思想的核心。这本身就是一个过程，毫无疑问，他在维也纳时就已经在某种程度上反犹了。但真正的关键时期是20世纪20年代初，当时它对他来说变成了一种意识形态。但还有一点，例如，“生存空间”的想法，那是后来才出现的。此外，反布尔什维克主义最初并不存在。它更多是与反犹太主义联系在一起的“反资本主义”，
linked to anti-capitalism at the beginning. It then changes. So by 1920, it's more anti-Bolshevism isn't there initially. It's more anti-capitalism with anti-Semitism linked to anti-capitalism at the beginning. It then changes. So by 1920, it's more anti-Bolshevism that's linked to that, anti-Marxism. And by 1924, when he's in prison, then the idea of living space becomes a crucial feature. And from between 1925 and 1928, speaks about about living space in every single speech practically so there's a development in Hitler's thinking but once they're there these ideas don't go away and that's the so there is development there when in case of the holocaust um his hatred of Jews is there from the beginning I mentioned before that in September 1919 in answer to a
在最初与反资本主义挂钩。后来它变了。所以到了1920年，更多的是与此挂钩的“反布尔什维克主义”，即反马克思主义。到了1924年，当他在监狱里时，生存空间的想法成为了一个关键特征。在1925年到1928年之间，他几乎在每一次演讲中都谈到生存空间，所以希特勒的思想是有发展的，但一旦这些想法形成，它们就不会消失，所以确实有发展。在大屠杀的情况下，嗯，他对犹太人的仇恨从一开始就存在。我之前提到过，1919年9月在回答一个
question while he's in the army he responds that it must be the aim of any national government to remove the Jews altogether. What does that mean, removal of the Jews, though? It probably meant no more at the time, as many other people were speaking in the same sort of way, of getting the Jews, removing Jewish influence, first of all, in Germany, and removing Jews practically, maybe physically, altogether from Germany. It doesn't mean Auschwitz and gas chambers in extermination camps. Even Hitler wasn't thinking of that at that time. And that comes much later. So there's a long process of development, not just in the spread of anti-Semitism within Germany, but in anti-Semitic legislation.
问题时，当他在军队里时，他回应说，任何民族政府的目标都必须是彻底清除犹太人。但是，“清除犹太人”是什么意思呢？在当时，这可能并不意味着更多，因为许多其他人也在以同样的方式说话，即清除犹太人，首先是清除德国境内的犹太影响，并从实际上，也许是物理上，将犹太人完全从德国清除出去。这并不意味着奥斯威辛和灭绝营里的毒气室。即使是希特勒当时也没有想到这一点。那是很久以后才出现的。所以这是一个漫长的发展过程，不仅是反犹太主义在德国的传播，而且是在反犹太立法方面。
From 1933, when Hitler comes into power, right down to 1941, the key moment when Germany invades the Soviet Union, when anti-Jewish policy now becomes a matter of, it's already become massively radicalized in Poland between 1939 and 41. And now it becomes an issue of removing the Jews, meaning now physically removing Jews. And the process is now set on the way of finding out how they can actually kill, exterminate the five or six million Jews that they've already calculated. And then, of course, the thinking was that after the war, it would go even further than that.
从1933年希特勒上台，一直到1941年德国入侵苏联这个关键时刻，反犹政策现在成为一个问题，它在1939年到1941年间的波兰已经变得极其激进化了。现在它变成了一个清除犹太人的问题，意味着现在要从物理上清除犹太人。这个过程现在已经开始，他们要找出如何真正杀死、灭绝他们已经计算出的五六百万犹太人。当然，当时的想法是，战争结束后，情况会比这更进一步。
They would exterminate Jews elsewhere and many others besides Jews. So it's, again, a development, not an instantaneous thing that comes at an early stage. Just a question sort of biographically about Hitler and anti-Semitism. There's some disagreement about this, as far as I can make out. So some historians think that he was anti-Semitic early, very anti-Semitic before the First World War in Vienna, kind of getting it from Karl Luger and from the atmosphere of Vienna in what, you know, early 1900s, 1890s Vienna, and others think it developed, became more extreme later as a reaction to the First World War.
他们会灭绝其他地方的犹太人，以及除了犹太人之外的许多其他人。所以，这又是一个发展过程，而不是在早期阶段就出现的瞬间事物。只是一个关于希特勒和反犹太主义的传记性问题。对此有一些分歧，据我所知。所以一些历史学家认为他在早期就是反犹太主义者，在一战前的维也纳就非常反犹，某种程度上是从卡尔·卢格和19世纪90年代、20世纪初维也纳的氛围中获得的，而另一些人则认为这是后来作为对一战的反应而发展和变得更加极端的。
What's your view now of that? Well, the view hasn't changed, really, from the view that I expressed in the first volume of my biography, which is that Hitler was anti-Semitic in Vienna, probably not in Linz, where he lived before he moved to Vienna in 1908, but in Vienna. And it's almost impossible to imagine that this person of all people was living in such an anti-Semitic city as Vienna, one of the most anti-Semitic cities in Europe at the time. He was reading, as we know, anti-Semitic tracts in newspapers
你现在对此有什么看法？嗯，我的观点并没有改变，真的，从我在我的传记第一卷中表达的观点来看，那就是希特勒在维也纳时就是反犹太主义者，可能在1908年搬到维也纳之前他居住的林茨时还不是，但在维也纳时是。而且几乎无法想象，这个人在当时欧洲最反犹的城市之一——维也纳，生活在这样一个反犹城市里，他会不是反犹主义者。我们知道，他在阅读反犹传单和报纸，
and so on in Vienna. The two people that he singles out for admiration in Mein Kampf were both racial anti-Semites. Georg Schönerer, the leader of the Pan-German movement in Austria, and Karl Lueger, the mayor of Vienna. Both of them, Schönerer and Lueger, racial anti-Semites. Hitler admired them both. So my point there in the biography was that at this period,
等等，在维也纳。他在《我的奋斗》中特别点名钦佩的两个人都是种族反犹主义者。乔治·冯·舍内勒，奥地利泛德意志运动的领袖，以及卡尔·卢格，维也纳市长。他们两人，舍内勒和卢格，都是种族反犹主义者。希特勒都钦佩他们。所以我在传记中的观点是，在这一时期，
Hitler was subjected to this. Almost certainly he was anti-Semitic in a general sense. But he had friends who were Jews at the time. He sold his pictures to Jewish dealers, people who were around him at the time, not that we have very good evidence from that period, but people around him at the time didn't notice his anti-Semitism, nor did they in the First World War. So it's fair to say that although Hitler was anti-Semitic at the time and racist, And one letter from the First World War in 1915 again says that this war will have served its purpose.
希特勒受到了这种影响。几乎可以肯定，他在一般意义上是反犹太主义者。但他当时有犹太朋友，他把画卖给犹太商人，那些当时在他身边的人，并不是说我们有那个时期非常好的证据，但当时在他身边的人并没有注意到他的反犹太主义，在一战中也没有。所以可以公平地说，虽然希特勒当时是反犹太主义者和种族主义者，而且一战中1915年的一封信再次说，这场战争将达到其目的。
It will remove foreignness from our country and will remove the inner internationalism, destroy the inner internationalism. Now, he doesn't mention Jews specifically, but it's almost unthinkable that Jews were partly in his mind at any rate at this. But the key period then comes when these personal ideas about Jews or abstract notions about Jews or whatever,
它将从我们的国家中清除异质性，并将清除内在的国际主义，摧毁内在的国际主义。现在，他没有具体提到犹太人，但几乎可以肯定，犹太人在某种程度上至少部分在他的脑海中。但关键时期出现在这些关于犹太人的个人想法或关于犹太人的抽象概念，无论是什么，
they become then in the later period of the First World War almost certainly deepened as Germany then moves towards defeat and then the shock of defeat and revolution. And then comes the period I've been talking about in the early 19, in the early period, immediately after the First World War, from 1919 almost right down to 1923, when this becomes absolutely central and not just central, but becomes an ideology now, not just a personal animosity, but an ideology which helps to explain the world. So I think that's the process that we have to look at rather than a single moment and say,
它们在一战后期几乎肯定加深了，因为德国当时走向失败，然后是失败和革命的冲击。然后就是我一直在谈论的时期，在早期，一战刚结束后的早期，从1919年几乎一直到1923年，这时它变得绝对核心，不仅是核心，而且现在变成了一种意识形态，不仅仅是个人仇恨，而是一种有助于解释世界的意识形态。所以我认为这是我们必须审视的过程，而不是单一的时刻，然后说，
was Hitler antisemitic in Vienna or was it later? It's a process where it moves through to the period, which is crucial then in the early 1920s. So we're in the 1920s. Obviously, we've still got quite a long way to go. We've recorded more than enough for one episode. So, I mean, Dominic, this was always going to happen, wasn't it? You know, we're discussing
希特勒是在维也纳反犹，还是后来才反犹？这是一个过程，它一直持续到20世纪20年代初的关键时期。所以我们现在在20世纪20年代。显然，我们还有很长的路要走。我们录制的内容已经足够一集了。所以，多米尼克，这总是会发生的，不是吗？你知道，我们正在讨论
the most important historical figure in recent history. We've barely scratched the surface. Yes, regular listeners will not be surprised to know that we have talked far too much. Anyway, so there's so much more to get into. We're barely, I mean, we're basically in the 1920s.
近代史上最重要的人物。我们几乎只是触及了皮毛。是的，经常听节目的听众不会惊讶地知道我们说得太多了。总之，还有很多东西要深入探讨。我们几乎，我的意思是，我们基本上还在20世纪20年代。
So what we're going to do, I think, is we're going to come back with Sir Ian on Thursday's podcast, talk about the Second World War, the question of madness, Hitler's suicide, and how Germany has reckoned with Hitler's legacy, the Nazi legacy, since 1945. So thank you for listening, and we will see you then. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad free listening There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以我们要做的，我想，是在周四的播客中请回伊恩爵士，谈谈第二次世界大战、疯狂的问题、希特勒的自杀，以及德国自1945年以来如何面对希特勒的遗产、纳粹的遗产。所以感谢您的收听，我们到时见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》，获取额外剧集、抢先体验、无广告收听。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。